I I find that um one of the secrets of
modern British life is the sense that it
often feels as though there isn't any
power
anywhere and so politicians spend a lot
of time I don't know thinking that
journalists have power and the
journalists maybe think the business
people have power and the business
people maybe think the politicians have
power and so on and so forth
the reality of being a minister is very
very odd so when I was um Secretary of
State for International Development I
was in charge of a budget of 20 billion
US a year so
13,000 million pound a year with almost
no constraint it was legally protected
by an act of parliament there was no
interference from the treasury there was
no interference from the prime minister
and yet oddly it didn't feel like the
kind of power that I had when I was
running a small charity on the ground in
Afghanistan so when I was on the ground
in Afghanistan I was under buildings we
had a couple hundred staff I could see
water supply going in I could see
clinics being built I could get involved
in the design of a balcony or worry
about where the electricity system was
coming in as a seet state you sit in an
enormous office and you sign Bits of
Paper that's like being a Roman Emperor
you know we come back Ian this is so I I
want to I'm going to throw that back at
you um it it is something that interests
me I mean you have the idea that
somebody like the emperor hadrien has a
lot of
power but of course he can only be in
one place at one time now he travels
around a great deal but wherever he is
he's just here and what he's doing at
the other end of the EMP Empire is
presumably a takes a certain amount of
time for the message to get through but
B is dependent on person after person
after person he can't actually I don't
know if he's standing in Britain worry
too much about exactly what's happening
in the design of a forum in Spain no
that's true and in in the Roman
Empire you can explain if you want to I
don't think it's a complete explanation
but you can explain the power l Ness of
the person apparently in power on
practical infrastructural grounds know
that know you've got your governor in
bethia and he's asked you a question but
the Letter's taken three months to get
to you and it's going to take three
months for you to send a reply by which
time he's going to have to have made his
own mind up you know you cannot control
that and I think ancient historians and
I'm you know I'm guilty here we we blame
that you know on the practicalities of
it but of course when talking to someone
like
you and saying well how does it feel
like to be a
minister as a minister you can
communicate instantly but you still have
that sense that things are going on
around you and you're not controlling
them and in a sense there is a you know
where we think power is there's often a
kind of black hole where the person
apparently wielding it and I think
that's an interesting word um is you
know is is itting there wondering what
the hell to do aren't they yeah I mean
it's this is partly I mean something I
think be definitely worth uh talking to
Mary much more about which is the
bureaucracy because of course the
reality is that and and Mary's wonderful
book which if any of you haven't bought
you must read um is very very good on
the fact that on the surface there are
very very few civil Serv vs working in
the Roman system a lot of soldiers an
enormous number of soldiers compared to
the population but surprisingly few
people that we would describe as civil
servants running this whole setup but my
experience as a minister is that the
relationship and I don't know whether
this would be true of an emperor with uh
an Emperor's civil servants but
certainly I changed in my life from
being a civil servant I was briefly a
British soldier I was then a diplomat in
the foreign office and I thought when I
became a minister I was just like a
senior civil servant so I could sit
around a table and I could have a sort
of debate like a seminar about what to
do or what not to do and we'd come to a
conclusion I'd make a decision it would
happen nothing of the sort it's
completely impossible to do things like
that I realized very very slowly that to
get anything done I had to actually do
what I hated doing which is create the
three-word slogan reach over over the
head to the public so in prisons for
example I spent um nearly 6 months
having a discussion on what we could do
about violence and prisons I was getting
absolutely nowhere was only when I said
to the BBC I will resign in 12 months
unless violence comes down in prisons
that I then got some power then suddenly
I could set up an operations room I
could focus on 10 prisons some money
came my way the civil servant sort of
woke up they had a Target to aim for and
everybody got behind the idea
um and I I'm I wonder whether there's
a anything that we can see of that
whether maybe and I I was thinking we
were talking about this in the Green
Room whether Emperors can't change small
things but they can occasionally pull
huge leaders so they can for example we
were talking about I can't remember who
is is it sep seus who suddenly makes
everybody citizen car okay so so how
does that work you wake up one day and
you suddenly think you're going to make
everybody a Roman
citizen those big changes are of course
the changes that none of us can actually
explain I mean you can see that the
Roman Empire quite resiliently carries
on probably a bit by luck um as much as
anything else you know they don't get
found out they don't ask too much um the
idea of Roman control is a very limited
uh bit of control
what you have in the
middle is a guy who if he's
successful has learned to act the part
of the emperor it's its performance
politics to suspect is not unlike our
own um and then very occasionally in the
history of what 300 years of the Roman
Empire you find someone like caraa who's
a frightful Bruiser by all accounts in
an absolute hard-headed face
guy right suddenly he
says every free person in the Roman
Empire will be a citizen it's the
biggest Grant of citizenship to ever
made anywhere ever can I can I interrupt
for a second so this is a guy who's he's
a professional military man he's quite
sort of tough he's quite ruthless and
then suddenly he manages to do this
quite extraordinary political thing I'm
not sure I mean he does have a good
reputation with the soldiers and he kind
of dresses up quite convincingly part of
the ACT you know little military skirts
um um and you know he's he's a guy who's
gone down in history as as you know kind
of nasty I mean his nastiest moment was
um having his brother who was partly a
co- rer with him his brother Gator
murdered in the palace um put to death
on his mother's lap well Gator Cried Out
apparently and this is either a
hopelessly pathetic moment in Roman
history or terribly poignant he said um
Mommy Mommy I'm being
killed and that caraca is The Mastermind
here um he's eventually assassinated by
uh the soldiers in the middle of a pee
actually he's having a pee while on
campaign and they choose that the moment
to do him in but his his major claim to
fame is this massive extension of
citizenship and we cannot understand why
he did
it